Welcome back to Vintage Egyptologist on
YouTube.  We are returning to the Valley
of the Kings to talk about a very
exciting text, the Litany of Re, where we
will explore some of the fabulous forms
of the sun-god including the great cat
and a jubilating baboon. So the text we
call the Litany of Re, the ancient
Egyptians named the Book of Adoring Re
in the West, is one of the first
attested ancient Egyptian Netherworld
books of the New Kingdom
We call them netherworld books because
we know them primarily from the Valley
of the Kings, we know them primarily from
the royal tombs of the New Kingdom but
they do appear in temples. There are
examples from the reign of Ramses II in
the temple of Abydos so these might have
been texts that you use in everyday life, at
least by priests, not just in tombs.  A
number of the texts we call the
Netherworld Books do have passages that
refer to them as having some
applicability for a person on earth and
the Litany of Re itself actually has an
introductory section that describes how
at least part of it is to be laid out in
registers so the the actual laying out
of these texts probably has a sort of
ritual function at least in in origin so
people would be drawing these images
from the Litany of Re, writing out the
text and that's part of the ritual,
this is part of how it all works.
That's probably the case at least for a
lot of these texts. So we have to
remember for the ancient Egyptians
these are not so much books to be
consulted, to be taken out and checked
for points of controversy or a point of
religious practice etc but these are
texts the laying out of which and the
reciting of which is part of what we
would call a magical actualization of
the texts. The first examples of the
Litany of Re appear in the tomb of
Thutmose III the and his Vizier Useramun.
just to give you a bit of historical
background Thutmose IIIis often
called the Napoleon of ancient Egypt
because he led successful military
campaigns up to the banks of the
Euphrates so in the tomb of Thutmose the
third, the Book of Adoring Re in the
West, the litany of Re, appears elements
of it appear within the decoration of the
tomb, within the chambers of the tomb, but
the text as a whole appears on the
shroud of Thutmose III, a
composition wrapped around the mummy
that would have been endowed by his son
and successor Amenhotep II. After these
double appearances in the tomb of
Thutmose III and its almost
contemporaneous appearance in the tomb
of his Vizier Useramun we don't
find the Litany of Re in the Valley of
the Kings again until the tomb of the
second ruler of the 19th dynasty the
tomb of Seti the first, probably the the
gem of the Valley of the Kings. He's the
father of Ramses the second (Ramses
the great), one of the most beautifully
carved structures really in Egypt. The
Litany of Re appears there early in the
19th dynasty and is more or less present
in virtually all of the tombs of the Ramesside
period. In the end it appears as
excerpts in the tombs of Ramses the
ninth and Rameses the tenth so almost at
the very end of the Ramesside period
traditionally it occurs in the first two
descending
passageways of the tomb. We have a plan
of the tomb of Ramses the fourth on a
papyrus that's now in the Turin
Egyptian Museum, and on that papyrus the
entrance corridors of the tomb are
labeled as the pathway of light the way
of Shu,
so the name the area of the tomb in
which the outer daylight might easily
access is the area in which we find
these addresses to the forms of the Sun
god Ra. When you walk into the tomb you
see this to the left and to the right,
often there are scenes sometimes of the
King offering to a god like Ra-horakhty or the four-headed ram that's
definitely the Mendesian Ram form that
appears a little bit later in the later
Ramesside Period.  We'll have to do a an entire episode - he's
exciting: four heads on one
neck, it's great great story and when you
walk in then to the initial sloping
corridor you see what we call the Great
Litany and these are addresses to the
seventy five forms of the Sun God some
of these are male forms like the god Shu
himself or Horus but others are
goddesses.  So the Sun God can be Tefnut
or Isis or Nephthys and to tackle this
rather complicated text we're going to
start with an address to the great cat
Okay now we're going to look at some of
the 75 addresses - we don't really
have time to look at all of them even in
several episodes so today we're going to
start off with one that Colleen
particularly likes, the 56th address -
it starts off like all with "hekenu en ek Ra" hail to you, Re,
high and mighty and here it addresses
"miw" and there's a fabulous
determinative of a seated cat so we not
only see the determinative of the cat
here in the hieroglyphic word but we
also see the picture of the cat
illustrating the Great Litany and then
an adjective that follows the word "miw"
for cat is "a-a" that means great.  So you
can see in the first word here "hekenu"
we have the second H, the twisted flax
that seems to be the wick of a candle
the k-basket, the horizontal water sign
for n, then we get the nw-pot and the
quail chick for "w" these are all
phonetic signs, 4 of them are uni
literal signs with one phoneme as a
value the nw-pot is a biliteral with
two phonemes "nw" and following
that group of "hekenu" we get then a
signifier or a determiner as it's called
a determinative and this one is the book
roll so it is a scroll of papyrus tied
up and that indicates often things that
represent concepts which is interesting
that here praise because it's not the
act of adoration which you normally see
a man with his hands raised in front of
him as they determined him for praise
instead here it's the concept of praise
probably because they're talking about
the text itself so this is one of the
important features of Egyptian script we
have uniliteral signs that represent one
phoneme, we have biliterals like the nw-pot
here that represent two phonemes
and then we have some triliterals that
represent three phonemes so there's the
scarab beetle for "kheper" There
are a number of forms in the Great
Litany relate to Khepry, there is even Kheprer, he who manifests, and in our
next episode we're going to be talking
about the introductory scene of the
Litany of Re, where within the solar
disk is a ram-headed man and the
scarab beetle as a representation of the
totality of the solar cycle so we get
"Hail to you high and mighty,"
another great determinative here with "qA"
it's a man with his arms raised up so
the motion of raising or exalting so one
of the things I always point out to
people when they ask why the Egyptians
don't adopt just an alphabetic script.
We will talk about that later,
the alphabetic scripts we know today
develop out of an abgab script so
basically alphabets without the vowels
coming from Egyptian script but the
Egyptians don't adopt that because using
these signifiers, these determinatives
allows them to indicate even aspects of
emotion, concepts behind the word that
might attach to a specific meaning of a
particular word in a way that an
alphabetic script simply cannot write. So
the Egyptians are able to write on
multiple levels at once - essentially
that's why their script works so
beautifully. So we have the general
introduction "Hail to you, Re, high and
mighty." Then we have a series of epithets
so after the name "miw a-a," the great cat
which is the name of the form of the God
exactly so so the way these litanies are
arranged is we get the introductory
praise then we get essentially an
address to that specific name form of
the god then what seemed to be a series
of epithets that describe the
significance of that form of Re and
then we get a recapitulation of the form
at the end so the first epithet is "nedj
netcheru," protector of the gods and then
"wedja medu"
is the term for judge and you might
think: What do cats have to do with
judgment? and we can find the answer
in another text in the Book of the Dead
where we have this fabulous depiction of
the Sun God as a cat slaying the chaos
serpent Apep. This is taking place at
Heliopolis at a place of judgment
and usually the cat is managing to hold
a knife and slice into Apep.  I think
there's a nice depiction of that at
Deir el-Medina and one of the tombs of
the workman there.  We can in fact - it's the
tomb of Sennedjem,
right here it's wonderful how the
Metropolitan Museum put so many of these
images available in the public domain
that is absolutely the way things should
be done and the reason why the cat is
holding a knife is because of that same
principle that John was just describing
with determinatives - it indicates a
signifier that the cat is killing, this
cat is slaying and the determinative to
kill or to slay is a knife so rather
than the cat using his claws to attack Apep,
he's using a knife which is a
hieroglyphic determinative illustrating
perfectly what you were saying about
hieroglyphs being able to be read on
multiple levels.  So this is one thing
always to remember for the Egyptians:
texts will evoke an image or an image
will really contain within it something
that is almost an inscription itself or
maybe a reference to other texts so
rather than showing the cat killing that
you can is holding the knife but a
serpent hieroglyph with a knife stuck in
it can be another way of writing up
because he needs to be magically killed
by the knife so it is on the one hand a
kind of a mythological image of a cat
using a knife to kill a snake but at the
same time it's a marriage of an image of
a cat killing a snake with the
hieroglyphic depiction
of the destroyed chaos serpent.  It's amazing
what they can do,
which is why they never give up
hieroglyphs for an alphabetic system. So
then the great cat is referred to as
"hery wedjat," so chief of the
council in the Council of the gods and
"khenty qereret," foremost of the cavern.
It's specifically the sacred cavern here
the qereret djeseret the secret
cavern which is slightly unusual they
don't normally describe the cavern of
the Netherworld or one of the many
caverns of the Netherworld as being
secret or set aside and the term djeser
in Egyptian of similar to the Latin
for sacred does mean set apart or
clear it can be even used to clear the
road, the road is sacred, the road is
clear after the great cat is called "foremost" of the sacred cavern, we then get a
recapitulation "tut is miw a-a"
indeed you are the corpse of the sacred cat so
in each of these 75 addresses the Sun
God is both that form, the great cat for
example, but also the corpse of that form
so how this works is essentially the
union of Re and Osiris. This is a
concept we'll come back to over and over
again as we look at the Netherworld Books,  although
it's not something you see a lot in
popular presentations of ancient
Egyptian religion but I think you would
agree it's the central mystery of
ancient. This is the "seshta wer"
the great mystery to which a number of
the Netherworld Books make reference,
essentially the Sun God as he descends
into the Netherworld is described, let's
say in the Book of the Hidden Chamber
that we call him "iwf" flesh
just the corpse as the husk of the Sun must
be rejuvenated
there are encounters between Re and
Osiris in another world and as we know
from The Book of the Dead and from a
text in the tomb of Ramses the Ninth, Re
can be considered tomorrow and Osiris
yesterday together. They're coming
together, the singularity of the union of
Re and Osiris brings about the new
creation,
so Osiris can personify certain aspects
of the Netherworld aspects of divinity
by being a corpse the "khat" which is a
feminine word - Osiris can embody other
aspects of a unified deity that can be
seen as feminine, so the "akhet," horizon
can be Osiris so Osiris reclines on the
horizon as we see at the end of the
twelfth hour of the Book of the Hidden Chamber and
as we see in the enigmatic wall and the
tomb of Ramses the Ninth.  Lots and lots of
complexity, but once you get some of
these fundamental principles in that
Egyptian religion at its heart is a
solar religion and the Sun god Re in the
heavens who travels through the
netherworld in the 12 hours of the night
unifies with his corpse as John
was just discussing unifies with the
corpse who is Osiris in the afterlife
and these are principles that are so
rarely explained that once you start
looking out for them if you pick up a
translation of the Pyramid Texts or the
Coffin Texts or the Book the Dead,
especially the Netherworld Books you can
start to see how central this concept is.
So even when the Sun God is the great
cat slaying the serpent Apep in the Book
of the Dead or the great cat who is the
judge or the chief of the council here
in the Litany of Re, you're getting it
something essential about ancient
Egyptian religion.
So in the netherworld books you'll read
the "ba demedjy," the unified ba in the
Litany in the addresses to Re you will
find a reference to something called the
"djeba demedj," the unified sarcophagus
form, unified enclosed one - this is one of
those cases where we still don't know
exactly how to translate it and as we
presented on Instagram this week even
just looking at material in books you
can have two images right in front of
each other that you've never seen
juxtaposed and figure out what's going
on so there's so much left to discover
just in books. So let's look at another of
the addresses so we've looked at one
Colleen likes, so let's look at one of which
I'm particularly fond, and that's the
baboon that's the one about the baboons
Now we're going to look at the 69th
address to write so it begins as all the
others "hekenu en ek ra, qa sekhem, "hecka and
that is followed by the word "iany" which
is baboon but the baboon is doing
something particular "hedjen"
jubilating, and this is the idea of
baboons worshiping the Sun God when he
rises and this relates to one of our
favorite depictions in any Egyptian
temple which is the Solar Chapel of
Medinet Habu.  So in the solar Chapel in
the right rear of the great mortuary
temple of Ramses the third of Medinet
Habu, if you walk into the temple you go
into the temple proper and go to the
right you'll find the Solar Chapel
you'll actually find a solar chapel
there in most New Kingdom and later
Egyptian temples. This is something we'll
go into when we discuss temple
architecture in Egypt but you'll see
there the souls of the eastern horizon
whom the Egyptians imagined as having
the forms of baboons worshipping the
Rising Sun rearing up and raising their
hands, as
baboons would do as the Sun would come
up and with the baboons is the king
because in the text known as the king as
solar priest this sort of compendium of
syncopated versions of the various sorts
of knowledge that the king is supposed
to possess is the high priest of the Sun
is the chief priest of the solar cult
the king is said to know this language
that the Eastern Souls chatter as they
worship Re so this mysterious language
of the baboons is something that the
Egyptian ruler is supposed to know. Not
only do Egyptian gods have the ability
to assume an animal form but this idea
of animals representing certain concepts
is something we find really with the
dawn of writing in Egypt between about
3500 and 3250
BCE
so it persists in Egyptian religion if
you go all the way back to cat humor in
ancient Egypt if we talk about the baboon
as a form of the god Thoth he is the
monkey who goes into Nubia to bring back
the goddess so when you see a baboon in
an ancient Egyptian scene you don't know
if you're looking at Thoth, if you were
looking at a soul from the eastern
horizon or if you're even looking at a
baboon worshipping Re in the company of
the king which is why it's so important
to be able to read the hieroglyphic text
because that's what tells you how to
interpret the iconography so in this Re
is not only the jubilating baboon,
referencing these souls of the eastern
horizon but he is specifically "wetjenet," He of Wetchenet, a place, a
toponym in the far southeast so Re in
the underworld is this jubilating
baboon but what are the jubilating
baboons they're personifications of
these elemental beings of the eastern
horizon who worship the Sun God so Re
is assuming the form of his
own divine worshipers looking ahead to
his own resurrection and rejuvenation
and this happens more than you would
think in ancient Egyptian scenes where
for example Ramses II at the temple of
Abu Simbel or Amunhotep III in
the temple of Soleb, it's the king as
king worshipping the king as god. So it's
similar here where it's the Sun God as
baboon worshipping himself who is the
Sun god, so for the ancient Egyptians all
of creation is a division of a
primordial oneness into various
constituent elements especially pairs
just as Egypt is Upper Egypt and Lower
Egypt, Egypt is the red land of the
desert in the black land of the alluvial
soil the egyptians like to see
everything as opposites or balanced
pairs in a cycle in a process that
maintains order and rejuvenation so Re
and Osiris are - I was just about to say Re and Osiris - a thing within itself can
have these elements, so a goddess can be
a counterpart of a god but within
herself a goddess like Hathor can be
both the beneficent cat goddess
Bastet and the angry warlike
bloodthirsty lioness goddess Sakhmet so
this duality exists within elements and
then those elements themselves are part
of some balanced pair in a larger area
so for Re to foresee his own
resurrection as one of the souls of the
eastern horizon is both an image of this
Egyptian concept of the interdependence
of these balance pairs and at the same
time it perpetuates the concept of
perpetuum mobile - the sun god is
entering another world now so that he's
going to come out on the other side and
literally combine with his own self,
worshiping elemental beings the souls of
the eastern horizon. And the next epithet
proves this perfectly: Khepri, the
manifesting one, so the baboon becomes
like the Sun the one that is going to
develop so when you see all those
scarabs in ancient Egyptian jewelry it's
one of the most common forms of amulets
they were actually used as stamp seals
you might see them in Egyptian themed
jewelry stores today every time you see
one of those scarabs you're actually
looking at a hieroglyph that is the triliteral
that we talked about a minute
ago which is "kheper," to become, to
manifest and that is indicative of the
sun's ability to undergo the continuous
cycle. One of the things that Sun God
does especially is he readies himself
for the encounter with Apep, the chaos
of it is "kheper kheperu," manifest
manifestations so this
ability to change in order to maintain
existence is very important for the
ancient Egyptians so they they don't
want an eternity of changelessness but
they want an eternity of a balanced
perpetual cycle so this djet-linear
eternity of a neheh-cyclical cycle of
events is really what is important for
the ancient Egyptians and djet and neheh,
the two forms of eternity are definitely
going to be a future video and this idea
of visible forms is what we see in the
next episode.  The iru
are the visible forms, so beings have
their kheperu, their manifestations and
they might manifest in some way that
isn't necessarily visible to the human
eye and the "iru" is the visible form so
here the God is the manifesting one who
is also proper of visible forms and the
determinative to iru for visible forms
is a
mummy because that is a very visible
form of a god or a person yes and then
finally we have the recapitulation here
"tut is khat iany duaty" - you
are indeed the corpse of the Netherworldly
Baboon. Don't forget to click subscribe
so that you don't miss a future episode
where we will be discussing the
introductory scene of the litany of Re, and
learn yet more about the Scarab, and "iwf,"
flesh the ram headed form of the night
sun and what these unusual snakes and
crocodiles are doing because they are
not fleeing inside the tomb as
representatives of evil but quite the
opposite